en 2011 il m'est arrivé une expérience
assez désagréable la nuit de la saint
valentin je me suis retrouvé à l'hôpital
et le diagnostic a été assez sévère pour
moi c'était crise d'angoissé
je crois que j'étais en train de mourir
dans une crise d'angoissé après un
burn-out numérique c'est à dire je passe
tellement de temps sur le net
tellement branchée tellement à discuter
à vouloir discuter avec des gens que
j'ai fini par exploser en vol comme je
suis écrivain je me suis dit je veux que
j'arrête six mois et je vais essayer de
prendre mes distances pour réfléchir sur
ce qui m'arrive
j'ai débranché j'ai commencé à reprendre
une vieille habitude de lire des livres
par exemple parce que quand on est
connecté en tout cas moi je vois
tellement de choses se passaient tout le
temps que je n'arrivais pas à lire des
livres je l' ai commencé que les finis
s'est jamais et là d'un seul coup je
retrouve du temps de lire très vite je
pense un livre que j'ai acheté deux ou
trois ans plus tôt et que j'ai pas lu
donc et je me dis je suis sûr qu'il ya
une réponse dans ce livre je me rappelle
que ça parlait des histoires d'écriture
et 20 des parts l'humanité au fil des
siècles
impossible de mettre la main sur ce
livre je fouille par tout le temps passe
et puis j'invite à la maison harvey qui
sait donner plus grand blogueur français
il était spécialiste de l'étude des
médias est de savoir ce qui se passait
qu'est ce qui change dans le monde
médiatique en général et narvik débarque
à la maison donc il va dormir dans une
cabane qu'on est dans le jardin et le
lundi matin il arrive au petit déj avec
un livre blanc la même couverture que
lieu que je cherchais et il a passé la
nuit à le lire et il me raconte que
l'auteur qui s'appelle clarisse en veine
smith a écrit le théorie sur laquelle
l'humanité a aimanté successivement
trois écritures
la première c'est l'écriture des langues
à moins de 3600 babylone
la seconde c'est à -620 jésus-christ
l'écriture arithmétique
la troisième c'est tout récent c'est
alan turing dans les années 30 qui
découvre comment on code qu'on va
programmer les ordinateurs c'est narvik
qu'à lui tout ce texte pendant la nuit
il me dit c'est extraordinaire parce que
quand on ajoute une écriture ses
possibilités humaines
d'un seul coup on étend son champ de
conscience en étant tout ce qu'on voit
et c'est bien ce que j'étais en train de
vouloir expliquer le fait d'être
connectés nous fait voir le monde très
différemment ça étant notre champ de
conscience dans une direction mais à la
fois ci on pratique une écriture
numérique on oublie les autres écritures
et on perd de certains champs en bus
était d'arriver à ne perdre aucun
essayez de vouloir élargir quand narvik
le matin me dit ça je suis vraiment
électrisés je ressens un profond bonheur
en fait parce que il a trouvé le livre
que je cherchais depuis longtemps et en
plus le contenu de ce livre va me faire
avancer sur mon chemin sont inquiètes et
c'est en fait la sérendipité quand le
croyait notre vie c'est ça c'est pas la
peine de faire une découverte génial
comme découvrir la pénicilline autre
chose c'est une petite découverte comme
ça suffit à nous enchanter et alors pour
définir la sérendipité on dit souvent
que c'est chercher quelque chose qu'on
ne trouve pas où chercher quelque chose
qu'on veut mais d'une manière inattendue
c'est un peu ce qui m'était arrivé là
c'est un hippie qui se joue sur deux
niveaux inattendue qui surviennent dans
notre vie et c'est inattendu nous
apporte une réponse en quelque sorte qui
va nous faire avancer
donc ces deux critères font que la
sérénité nous nous procurons pas mal de
plaisir
la psychologue isabelle filliozat dit
qu'on est heureux à deux conditions
la première c'est qu'on se sent
connecter aux autres on est dans un
groupe
or ces masques ont le sens connectée on
n'est pas seuls et la seconde c'est
quand on progresse sur une quête qu'on
s'est donné et la sérénité
elle dépend d'un manque de connexion
connexion avec narvik avec des amis et 2
le contenu de livres me fait progresser
sur mac est donc la sérendipité cathala
rinne
elle remplit en général ces deux
dimensions et c'est pour ça qu'elle nous
procure du bonheur
une fois qu'on sait ça on peut se dire
bon je vais attendre que la serbie
pittet me tombe dessus
moi je crois que si on commence à
détricoter la sérendipité
on va commencer à trouver des idées pour
pouvoir essayer de la faire sur venir
plus souvent dans votre vie il ya une
dimension qui est le fait de se
connecter avec les autres mais pour
faire ça il faut sortir de chez soi il
se déplacer et ça c'est ça peut être
possible dans le monde physique mais
c'est aussi vrai dans le monde numérique
c'est à dire sur les réseaux sociaux est
le seul critère qui me paraît important
c'est d'être à l'écouté des autres aussi
on ne veut pas écouter ce qui se passe
sur ce réseau qu'ils soient physiques ou
pas physique on va entendre toujours la
même chose donc il faut être à l'écouté
et le troisième critère très important
c'est que il faut que tout le monde sur
ce réseau et le droit de s'exprimer même
les plus petites bois parce que c'est
peut-être une toute petite voix qui dit
quelque chose d'à priori anodin qui va
réveiller en nous quelque chose on voit
qu'il s'agit de trois liberté la liberté
de déplacement
la liberté d'écouter et la liberté de
s'exprimer
on n'a pas beaucoup progressé parce que
là dans nos pays occidentaux on est déjà
très libre pour développer la cire un
député ça veut dire qu'il faudra être
beaucoup plus libres qu'on ne l'est déjà
alors je vais essayer de vous montrer
comment on est tous capables de devenir
beaucoup plus libre et assez simplement
quand vous créez des liens sur un réseau
social par exemple ces liens qu'est ce
qu'ils font sur la carte imagine r du
réseau social qui nous interconnecte
tous on ajoute des connexions comme ça
et plus on ajoute des connexions plus
cette carte se complexifie vous imaginez
par exemple une carte michelin ya
beaucoup de route mais vous ajoutez en
permanence des nouvelles routes mais
cette carte elle représente un
territoire c'est la société et plus et
la carte se complexifie plus en fait la
société est en train de se complexifier
c'est à dire que une interaction qui se
produit à l'endroit de la carte va
pouvoir se propager plus loin sur la
carte on a un pouvoir énorme c'est quand
on crée des liens
on complexifie le monde et mettez vous
dans la peau des gendarmes avec leur
radar leurs panneaux et à tout moment
une nouvelle route qui se créent partout
comment ils font pour contrôler ce qui
se passera t route s'y mettent un radar
là tout le monde veut passer sur la
route d'à côté et jamais ils vont
pouvoir contrôler les gens donc si la
carte et le territoire sont en train de
se complexifier en permanence les gens
qui sont censés contrôler ce qui se
passe sur ce territoire ont de plus en
plus de mal en 1977
valente enter chine qui cybernéticiens a
démontré un théorème mathématique qui
explique que quand on a un système
l'élément de supervision de contrôle du
système doit être aussi complexe que la
partie la plus complexe du système les
gendarmes doivent avoir de plus en plus
de moyens aux besoins plus de caméras la
force qui contrôle ne peut pas avoir
autant de moyens que l'ensemble du
réseau
la course est perdue d'avancé
l'organisme qui contrôle ne peut plus
contrôler il ya un nouveau théorème qui
apparaît c'est plus je crée du lien plus
se complexifie mais plus eu complexifie
puis je me libère
c'est pas gagné d'avancé dans tous les
pays démocratiques
en ce moment tous les gouvernements sont
en train de passer des lois pour limiter
nos possibilités d'interconnexion les
uns avec les autres
par exemple en france vous avez tous
entendu parler d'hadopi aujourd'hui on
discute de loi qui reviendrait avant de
publier
chose sur internet il faut qu'une
instance vanille de se compromettre sur
internet vous savez qu avant de publier
une bêtise sur facebook il faut que
quelqu'un de valide notre bêtise qu'on
est des millions des milliards à poster
sur facebook dont il faudrait des
milliards de policiers pour vérité ce
qu'on dit c'est pas possible on est dans
un monde comme dans toutes les histoires
il ya souvent deux camps qui s'opposent
d'un côté les citoyens qui naturellement
vers la complexité même s'ils n'ont pas
compris que ça allait mener à la liberté
et de l'autre côté on a les gens qui
contrôlent qui veulent réduire cette
complexité eux leur obsession c'est
contrôlé aujourd'hui qu'on est en état
de crise on a besoin de serendipity pour
s'interconnecter les uns avec les autres
alors c'est très bien on est très
puissant il faut penser qu'on peut tous
se connecter se lier plus son seul ira
mieux ça sera mais attention gare au
burn out
parce que moi c'est un peu à ça que j'ai
explosé dont garou burn out
mais continuez à vous lire